Hello Freak bitches.
This is everything.
I own it as well.
That's insane.
Right in my bag back.
He has A.
I mean that's not even a really large backpack.
Like if you brought that elk hunting,
people would be upset with you.
A little man purse.
Yeah.
So a man purse backpack.
My chords and my ipad stuff by that
and I travel all over the world.
Wow.
Pack really carefully as you can imagine.
Very petite shirts,
three pair of pants,
three pairs of shorts,
a rain jacket too.
Lightweight hoodies,
long sleeve tee shirt.
I could pretty much recite.
I never felt more liberated than when I got rid of all my stuff and I'm in a
different country.
I have a couple of weeks.
A lot of people say,
hey,
why not the roller bags,
Dave,
if you travel in any kind of third world country down cobblestones.
Uh,
I actually had a roller bag,
but I ditched it my first trip to London,
a change trains four times going up and down these damn stairs where the clunk,
clunk,
clunk her back.
I said,
you know what?
This really sucks.
I'm going to carry it on my body.
So that's um,
I don't get any money from these guys,
but as a Tom,
Ben,
Bi,
h,
n fantastic travel bags,
uh,
so well configured,
you wouldn't believe the stuff I get in there.
I even had my whole workout gym and that thing man really
kind of stuff's in there that you carry around with you everywhere.
Now this Tom Ben,
is this for hiking or is it just primarily a trap?
The travel ban.
I want to take a serious hike with it,
but,
uh,
it looks like it's pretty sturdy,
very sturdy.
I use packing cubes.
There's different packing ways.
A good resource for your listeners that travel full time.
Go to one bag.com.
He has many recommendations for various bags and uh,
where you can just basically one carry on bag and travel anywhere in the world
for several weeks at a time if you want to smell one bag.
A lot of this stuff is high tech.
I just washed my tee shirts out in the sink.
Well,
if it was,
if you were,
um,
one of the things that I've found from hiking and camping for long periods of
times,
wool was great.
There's a great company called first light,
first Lit II that I'm a buddy minds,
part of my friend Ryan Callahan.
I'm out of Montana and actually catch them.
I met them in Montana,
but they make look will outer gear and inner gear like long johns stuff along
those lines.
Fantastic.
A lot of hunting gear and you can wear that stuff for days,
days,
and it doesn't smell
well because a lot of this stuff is this stretch polya mine.
It's like a little of that Hashtag,
a nylon type material,
which real stretchy.
It's a silver impregnated silver.
Uh,
help stop the bacteria from.
Okay,
so you can get like three or four days out of this t shirt.
Really?
Yeah.
It doesn't stink.
Maybe you could.
Well,
I stink.
I'm a stinky person.
Check this out.
I can train a rubber band and I used to metrics I can do.
Good morning.
What is the amount of tension on that rubber?
They just say heavy duty.
But remember,
the further you stretch it,
the smarter it gets.
It gets this old man.
Plenty of a stretch.
Maybe not you,
but Milton Berle,
Sid Caesar,
they.
I mean,
it was still guys plan,
you know?
Wow.
Yeah,
yeah.
There was a lot of stuff came to us and he got to see all those people should
not show night after night if tonight.
And I just,
if I was done work,
I'll go shit in the back of the room,
you know,
sometimes my wife would come,
you know.
Wow.
And there it was no big deal after awhile,
you know,
it's crazy.
I got a tape of him.
I got a tape of him on New Year's Eve,
I think it's New Year's Eve.
[inaudible]
89 or 90.
The guys did the soundman took it.
It was closed circuit the circuit in the room and just in the room and they put
a vh a vhs and Beta Max,
whatever the hell it was.
And he's drunk.
His toupees Kinda crooked.
And Joey,
Remember Joey Villa?
He was a comic,
like a real,
you know,
real hacky,
thethey guy.
He was in splash that show.
Okay,
so you had joey villa opened the door and then driessen open for a Tom Dreesen
opened for a Sinatra and he did a show upstairs and downstairs he was drunk on
his ass and archer and I have a tape of it somewhere.
I still have it somewhere and he played.
He says,
I don't care.
I play upstairs.
I played downstairs.
If they pay me,
I'll sing in a phone booth.
He didn't care at that point,
you know.
Wow.
How old was he back then?
I don't know.
He just turned to hundred night.
It was like 1990.
So that was probably the beginning of the end.
Right before he started losing a little.
He had a teleprompter onstage,
you know,
he was reading though,
he wasn't completely out of it,
but you know,
did he died in [inaudible] 99,
if I'm not mistaken.
So,
uh,
he would forget his lyrics.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Because it was so hammered.
It was just.
No,
no.
I just think he was getting older and I think to be honest,
my opinion that kept them out there too long,
you know,
I think whoever the powers may be,
I don't know who that was.
I think he stayed a little too long there,
you know,
but I hate to see him.
I saw him in [inaudible] 82 when I first.
I got to town and 80.
I saw him.
Nineteen 81.
Eighty two,
83 in those days.
It's Jesus.
I mean that was something I saw Sammy Davis,
you know.
Wow.
Yeah,
I saw all those,
you know,
Johnny told those guys that were there.
I saw a lot of stuff that people were gone and you know.
Yeah.
You like caught the bridge for the last of the.
Exactly.
Absolutely.
When I moved in it was 350,000 people.
Well the,
I was friendly with the,
uh,
casino,
the Joe Pesci character,
Tony Spilotro,
that character.
I was friendly with that guy.
I was a bouncer.
He would come into the club,
the time on the club,
you'll just give me a 20,
you know me.
He was giving me 20 house for years.
If I was a bartender,
you send up a 20.
He was always a good guy to me.
Now I didn't know what he did,
but he didn't do.
He was good to me.
I didn't know the,
the uh,
I didn't know that Deniro character him.
I never knew he was around,
but I didn't know him.
But the Pegi character,
uh,
Tony splotch show and he had a guy fat Herbie and I was there.
His son got married.
I was the bouncer at the wedding to make sure FBI didn't get into the,
into the wedding.
I swear to God they had a balance here at the wedding bouncers Tuxedo.
I was about to do it and make sure nobody that's not on that list doesn't come
in,
but they're worried about the FBI.
They were worried because at the time there was a lot of,
you know,
it was a small town.
It was easy.
I mean,
you know,
they were doing whatever they were doing.
I mean,
I don't know,
you know,
I mean,
I was never privy to any of that.
Well,
you're putting out a certain type of frequency,
right?
I mean,
that's what you're putting out.
If you're putting out a frequency,
look what you're saying is you want to own all the react videos.
That's the greedy can frequency you throughout the greedy combat bat signal and
you're letting everybody know you're a piece of shit.
You're a piece of shit and you want to steal money.
Well,
you know,
the best part is that stealing money,
right?
I mean,
that's stealing money.
If you make a reaction video,
you want to watch two girls,
one cup or guy getting run over by a buffalo,
they want money from you watching that video,
that stealing.
What they've done is they've used lawyers to circumvent the system.
They've jacked the system and they're going to try to steal.
Have they actually copyrighted the word react.
So is this valid?
So they,
they,
uh,
they retracted.
What happened was the Internet lost its shit as you would expect.
And these guys,
there were videos on youtube which were live streams.
These were so funny when this was going on.
Essentially what they were is the subscriber count of their channel shortly
after the controversy had hit and it will just like fell off a cliff,
like it should go to zero.
He never went to 100 percent.
Go to zero.
It should go to zero.
It never went to zero.
Don't deserve anything.
Yeah,
that's what they want to do.
You really want to reach out to everyone using the word react in a video and you
want money from them.
Fuck you.
You're everything that's wrong with distributing content over the internet.
That's everything that's wrong with it.
You've taken one of the sneakiest most diabolical fucking tricks and all the
legal system and you've applied it to this open free world of the Internet and
you're a piece of shit.
That's a parasitic behavior.
Let me ask you something.
That's cancer.
I agree.
They came back,
retracted it.
Apologize.
Fuck them.
Fuck them for even thinking that showed the,
okay,
now you're going to give him a second chance.
Fucking chances.
You can't think like that.
You can't do that.
You can't.
You can't go after people.
For some it's not like it has anything to do.
Anything you create.
Yeah,
you're just stealing their wares.
There were some stories going around that they had effectively shut down like
these small time,
Walmart completely like people who had the hots for who they.
Again,
the fine brothers.